treinen the story they've had other
scenes have also tried to said you know
we have good players too let's try and
push ourselves out there now it started
off with the bang I mean we were talking
about again Evo Japan six out of the
eight countries in the top eight from
different places around the world and
that was great that was great and I mean
we saw it and almost every other top
eight
around the world we saw some ridiculous
things as well sometimes we'd see you
know more Koreans or more Japanese I
mean more Americans even winning a lot
of these massive events even Europe
leading some of the master events to I
mean when I tell you when we were at Evo
Japan that's why I posted it on my
Twitter I was like I knew Tekken was
gonna be ridiculous this year it's
always been going up but the fact that
we have so much diversity character
diversity country diversity in that Evo
Japan top eight told me everything I
needed to know about this season and
look at what's happened it's crazy man
you call their birth no oh wow and I
believe they have a blind pink coming up
yeah don't know but book has he's
definitely so you never know my man
might actually surprise a few people out
there I don't think the dog is gonna
switch from a puma I think he's gonna
stick oh we're gonna have a good old
slope it was not the matchup I expected
it is the first two three right yeah
there is that kind of cushion to be able
to say okay let me try out Brian you
know he did get him out of the really
sticky situation in this like in his
previous match oh no why not my knees
brian is very strong
yeah trying Brian let's go yeah right
right I'm sure Jimmy out there's you
know smiling a little bit the most
animation he's like look down with like
[Laughter]
they always come back always come back
things get bleak out there pull out the
bride here we go guys
fury fury I remember this winners finals
first the three Sevilla long said ladies
and gentlemen and a long said with the
crowd behind book that is gonna be I
think a big factor here in the matchup
but let's see book again not what the
hits it on he wanted to hear the energy
from the crowd how will sing without
running this outfit speaks to me I'm
about this oh yeah okay mister fashion
guy because you can wear that shirt
mister rip you're about the side cyborg
ladies guys you're going for throws
alright
nice choice there look book is like I
know just waiting him out here trying to
figure out what's oh there's a week
funny yeah pushes them towards the edge
of the stage here but if this weird to
see people just normally walk back and
take I'm like what does he in fact I
should oh great oh thanks for taking the
easy easy tears are going back and forth
the counter heads
that first round of course going to
Bulow beget up threes like that have
been so crazy today and it's happened so
many times
oh nice blue spots that we got bill out
two rods up best game walk in trouble
right now going to this third round game
number one yeah no more walls here at
the bottom of the stage you see the
crowd get rowdy great walk there Coleco
calm the Liao's playing yeah
dr. combi down to orbital honest it
feels like he's played this this is a
first ten right now and he's up like
eight seven zero it feels like right now
watching him play just feels he's so
comfortable yep your timing and
everything yes like he's running in
tanta he's like you know I feel
confident it's crazy man people need to
realize that below has been placing high
in tournament without good one you know
you've even picked up the camera he's
been rocking the Brian again huge
placement in every tournament this guy's
gone to you know very very sauce man
Brian so he's catch it to use and he
plates a very different style of black
like he still uses you know the tech
trash you know the taunt jet over he
goes for those things but just affect it
like where he places them is completely
different than most yeah well they'll
other tools I should say but here we go
game number two this is a first two
three yeah book did go to characters
like I wasn't sure if he was gonna if he
was gonna do it an app like I mean what
else could he go to you can go to geese
and Akuma right and like they've got a
lot of geeses attic room as a [ __ ]
fun one
yeah who mindlessly just think our here
with the gym
what are you doing over there
sighs okay so funny so good
regular throw up in the middle of the
screen yeah he wasn't ready for it damn
you had a channel in the second for
Carrie there we go it's the wall oh nice
ootek be careful how nice you do is get
a stay crowd so what good is a witness
the guys will even give me something
once and for all once again no drop this
time it's got the wall yeah just catches
the timing again good oh wow
seven golden and couldn't just to finish
the strength of calm one I would work
the same that wouldn't be fun I'm
getting too cocky now how do you stop
you did you change shirts again you did
[Laughter]
back on another team damn I wish you had
that that's tight and they just are
bringing more close to the venue right
yeah you've already changed outfits one
nice looking for with this the pacing of
this matchup is just kind of throw me
off I thought you didn't start going in
more on each other yeah but they're
really really looking for those hits
sure this should be the route as well
okay look Wow right now
second game this is the first two three
though allow first game on this side
yeah don't want to go down to Oh buddy
nice part is there she was in the lay
there gave him a chance to stop that off
it's a little damage because of it
should be able to get the wall as well
yeah generally you lost husband ain't
quite patient but he still got town here
looks timing there for the league's do a
lot better now yeah look in this entire
match has been getting a lot of counted
so that's pretty much how he's been
starting all of his offense down for one
car trying to sidewalk yeah book is very
good and hitting for me to down for one
more that was a clear download in the
timing right definitely a lot more
comfortable with what Bill I was doing
the sidewalk timing everything when he
wants to come in I feel like it's time
guys I think he has to pull out Akuma I
notice what he's probably thinking about
right yeah of course
alright Bulow was to move no switch here
comes a demon go for the Haram pick
who's that excuse we wanted the statute
allows you to pick the character I
wasn't talking about the statue bro not
the carrot I don't even know what's up
in any role what's below thinking what's
going on oh wait he's still thinking
about it
the plot thickens we were we were just
talking about how we might not have a
machine of the morrow if this is what oh
my god even tried he tried he tried on
checked his leg he's like ah he tried a
different demon that he was thinking
about the devil jin you trying to keep
your halal out here monies to you he
wants to make Tekken Gregor yeah here we
go
I steal off a slip
and he just goes straight up to Mishima
dojo so basically just rematches took a
very long time to do it
yeah I didn't take any time as you want
to man think about it you know it's true
teacher II though man you got to think
about it man that match went back and
forth for those two those two opening
matches we're now one one yeah
this match is so important yeah I mean
it feels like I mean from what we've
seen it feels like book has gone in a
read of the timing right a read on the
pace of the matchup
but maybe he thinks maybe there's some
other stuff he can do maybe the smother
something he could pull out in the
matchup
we all had a lot of time to think about
it and you know even when we were
watching the matches you downstairs in
pools you know Pilar was watching
attempt to do to every much saying okay
you could have done this should have a
very analytical other player as long so
he understands what he needs to do all
right nice giving a big counter hit to
start it off Oh try to keep them there
let's put the jet upper yeah that's
happen instead water bug has been
carrying this tiresome process well as
the counter hit Lord she also is a
horrible girl covers a lot a lot of
options very fast two or four doesn't
punish wife and one does it I felt my
neck cracks nasty still coming out there
that 34 has been booked Savior in this
set get off the lot using that you knew
while stunning punished oh no he's not
ahead
capable auditor readjust every time and
answers back with the perfect around the
be so match of peace fun
cave number three oh my twin Lancer
thought he was gonna you know go forward
both you stop being so patient
oh he misjudged the walls is shinning
all man he's gone City he's gonna makers
now man he just hopped over to Lowell
look play the killer you think Brian so
jumpy what he missed the quarter circle
back to book unfortunately from below he
thought that he had Lou the confirm but
if the axis kind of messed up yeah you
slightly off axis to but it just he
didn't whip this spring
he's the axe kick on the grounds like me
definitely a favorable our ranks try to
do the job this could be any visited up
book is up now in the matchup this is
crazy
look want much away from going to the
grand finals hair in spy lab for the LCQ
it's not even gonna try wait
you know weights I don't watch if you go
downstairs real quick or might find a
tile answer real fast I just come back
upstairs we'll cover for you yeah Wow no
characters like I don't agree with this
this is grass I mean there must be a
reason for sure yeah he should have
definitely I thought integrity but for a
cream oh but maybe he's sick maybe
book was doing earlier versus other like
Akuma's right is pairing he was really
ready to stop all demon flute accomplice
he was just so prepared for the matchup
maybe that's what he was looking at you
saying he was being super analytical
with it every other edge maybe that's
the process people comfort zone he's
thinking about is not the three games
maybe he's thinking about he still has a
loser's bracket that's that's true
that's true I mean I don't know we'll
have to wait and see but here's the kuma
is different I don't know maybe he's
hasn't the confidence but either way
he's stuck in with Brian now he's
definitely locked in the ground while
standing one here comes Buck go the
other way
what kind of mix-up Oh we'll get right
to the dangerous down one we saw him
this will close out one of the rounds
long before
my financials but why are you a Finnish
damn nice okay okay
has he moved there from below but it was
a perfect perfect one yeah yeah it was
dangerous no cuz if look I should go to
read and goes a temporary punished yeah
the wolf sign oh yeah let me see oh this
is great kid - somebody was ready for it
that one
great right now flowey something he has
rage and we saw what he did in that
first game when he bought it back yeah
it's just really good at like picking
you top spot don't win get me to trade
you treat the patients that book to
recognize that that's string yeah block
belly yep
he blocked that lowing and he knew that
mids coming I can punish that one I'll
punish that one instead
back up allow delayed it and feel book
was like knobs don't worry about that
the same thing but it's gonna hurt this
is going to hurt wall again oh oh my god
yeah can i still ain't ecto oh my gosh
here we go the other way
yeah oh I like the presence of mind
there from booking look at that one
round away from moving on a grand finals
he's welding it down in Thailand here
pending home tough oh you know like a
great year for book but that's also he I
remember you didn't travel that much so
he I mean if you had traveled to maybe
three more events two more events he
might have already been qualified yeah
playing like this yes playing the way
he's playing right now below these are
the back foot managers know what to do
not punish 10 frames here we go 55 self
right there what's the mix-up he
handsome enraged you can have to be
careful they're not belong knows what I
have to get in here he's got rage
available now whenever
wolf tip Oh Nick this is huge it's
definitely gotta be it that was a very
nice sidewalk there yeah just yet just a
small little adjustments that he's
making is definitely edging him closer
and closer you saw what happened in that
last round you almost bought that back
yep okay wait a minute
it's a good start Wow where you got for
us how we did another one no I like the
spike right that is the orbit what a
plot run punished though oh he had it
there that could have been it oh but he
has raged in that rate Drive does a ton
of damage to see what he does
are we gonna get a final match oh he's
gonna bring it back patience we got into
a final match in the winners finals oh
this is about to be good I can't handle
no no no he's not sure he's not sure
stage I think it's David this is tensed
up guys this is tense stuff
who is gonna make it into the grand
finals here in the LCQ 2019 so we've
gone straight we've gone no change no
change your cards Josh yeah
oh wait is he this this coaching is what
to him to come up there arsalan in the
crowd just give it a cushion just got
better
damn that was good vibe you the final
match fight
all the second heat able to land what is
that
jumping jab action I like giving you if
considering the pace these guys both
went into the matchup earlier on where
they're very slow pace but now these
guys are starting to turn it up yeah
especially with the compact late the jab
really controlling a lot of the matchup
here what do you doing interrupts it
nice threads needle I have two patients
both players right now just breathing it
out not forcing any forces it actually
feels like it's crazy because he's small
hesitation even like the fact that
they're just waiting on the ground isn't
too heavily effective what happened
low for Mike I just broke how he like
straight way like that stop Chuck thank
you oh I'm Johnny interesting the thing
about that is if you drop the forward
for two and your opponent ducks you will
get launched so it's very tight maybe
didn't have the confidence in it dancing
a little bit just advanced trying to
push up to this wall trying to get that
count here for putting over looking from
you how to count hand ever the Japs put
the new finishes drink here we go Oh
gotta be careful now what I'm gonna
stick with punish yeah final game in the
final game you quit this you stop
playing now don't break on the 1+2 again
yeah Oh starting to chop away at him
[Music]
look at that the laws one round away
from grand finals here this is crazy
but I have a feeling books gonna bring
it
Oh will be that will be moving on stayin
alive in the Last Chance Qualifier
that's gonna book book and then losers
sigh they don't have a caucus the de
Zeeuw of the loser's bracket right now
yeah